[Música]
el dolor es tan fuerte que tengo que
irme del trabajo directamente al
sanatorio necesitó atención médica
urgente y sin embargo me veo enredado en
trámites administrativos en una planilla
hablo con la recepcionista que realmente
no sé qué me está diciendo porque me
duele y necesito pasar urgentemente a la
sala de emergencias lo consigo entró a
la sala de emergencias me colocan un
suero y medicación firmo con la mano del
suero un depósito de dinero porque
aparentemente mi cobertura de salud está
cortada
llega un familiar y comienza a ayudarme
con estos trámites mientras yo aguardó a
que me realicen la ecografía el estudio
de imágenes con el que dicen que
probablemente puedan arribar a un
diagnóstico de la causa de mi dolor
sigo ocupándome de trámites
administrativos pero me hacen la
ecografía y en la ecografía encuentra
una gran piedra en mi vesícula unas
cuantas horas después el dolor comienza
lentamente a ceder y poderme a mi casa
con medicación una dieta y la indicación
de ver próximamente un cirujano
próximamente pidió al turno no lo
consigo lo tengo tengo el turno falta un
montón pero tengo el turno estoy un
poquito más tranquilo el día de la
consulta aguardo el doctor está atrasado
está bastante atrasado
me informa que me va a tener que operar
que me va a tener que sacar la vesícula
pero que no me preocupe porque el
procedimiento es mínimamente invasivo y
con rápida recuperación sin embargo me
voy a tener que ocupar de trámites
administrativos
tengo que autorizar otro estudio de
imágenes en en este caso una resonancia
y además tengo que autorizar la cirugía
que la va a ser por vídeo buenísimo pero
quizás no tenga cobertura al 100% yo
tengo que pagar
además me voy a tener que ocupar de ir
al sanatorio a conseguir una fecha para
poder operarme y un lugar para poder
internar me
pasaron seis semanas pasé siete horas en
la guardia tiene ocho planillas y seno
de trámites administrativos y gaste
bastante dinero pero hoy me operan no me
operan como no me esperan no no hay
camas como no hay cama no hay cama bueno
me quedo quizás se produce el milagro y
se libera una cama escuchó una
conversación la secretaria internación
habla con la encargada de saleh y le
dice que la vesícula puede subir
internarse al lado del apéndice de cama
si hoy me curan claro la vesícula era yo
soy médico y de los que estamos
profundamente comprometidos
y creemos firmemente en la necesidad de
un cambio y además trabajamos
activamente para esto no es lo mismo la
enfermedad que el padecimiento no es lo
mismo tener una piedra en la vesícula
que saber me enfermo tener que operarme
dejar de trabajar y depender de mi
familia no es lo mismo conocer la
enfermedad que tiene una persona lo cual
es muy importante sino además conocer a
la persona que tiene esa enfermedad
entonces la propuesta es que hagamos
juntos un análisis epistemológico de lo
que está sucediendo en nuestra práctica
cotidiana
hoy en día en salud si en algún momento
digo medicina en lugar de salud no dejo
de incluir a todos aquellos que no somos
médicos
que esperábamos que queremos que
necesitamos en la consulta con el médico
y porque a pesar de los descubrimientos
científicos y avances tecnológicos
muchos médicos y pacientes no estamos
conformes con esta forma de hacer
medicina está que no es la única pero
claramente es la hegemónica o
predominante en países como nuestro
medicina que además es normativa y nos
dicta lo que significa estar sano o
estar enfermo nos dice lo que quiere
decir salud y enfermedad si el médico
nos dice lo que quiere decir estar sanos
o enfermos claramente como pacientes
solemos no participar activamente en
nuestra propia sanación y curación
'esperamos tratamientos mágicos recetas
de medicamentos pedidos de estudios
complementarios hagamos el análisis
definamos paradigma como un conjunto de
teorías o hipótesis que aceptamos como
verdad para que nos dejen trabajar
plantearnos preguntas y buscar
respuestas dentro de un marco de
referencias como un gran paraguas de
contención un ejemplo de otra disciplina
podemos tomar lo de la física y el
cambio que sucedió con la teoría de
newton
de la gravedad con el enfoque luego de
la teoría de la relatividad y más aún
con la teoría cuántica
mirando desde ese lugar nuestra práctica
asistencial cotidiana hoy el paradigma
de nuestra medicina de nuestra sanidad
define a la salud como una ciencia que
estudia y trata enfermedades que son del
cuerpo y requieren un tratamiento
técnico y un conocimiento y una
infraestructura
repito ciencia enfermedad cuerpo y
técnica ciencia enfermedad cuerpo y
técnica claro
tratamos cuerpos los médicos tratamos
cuerpos y esos cuerpos no dejan de ser
objetos un objeto de estudio un objeto
de tratamiento nosotros sabemos de
tejidos de órganos
vemos gracias a los avances tecnológicos
de nuestros estudios complementarios de
imágenes la enfermedad de la patología
apostada en los tejidos y en los órganos
vemos la enfermedad en el estudio
complementario de imágenes allí está la
enfermedad
sabemos de aparatos de sistemas de
enfermedad de patología de diagnóstico
de pronóstico de tratamiento
habitualmente no somos conscientes de
esto es lo que hacemos es lo que
aprendimos es lo que hacemos es lo que
enseñamos
tanto es así que fraccionamos al
organismo en territorios de
especialidades
yo soy especialista en uretra yo me
dedico a páncreas yo sé de retina
decimos incluso muchas veces que el
paciente no tiene nada si no observamos
evidencia de enfermedad orgánica
enfermedad física decimos que no hacemos
nada si no indicamos un estudio un
medicamento o un procedimiento decimos
que no tenemos nada por hacer en las
etapas terminales de un paciente en su
vida cuando quizás tenemos tanto por
hacer o hemos hecho tanto acompañando y
escuchando
nada significan muchas de las palabras
de nuestro discurso médico para los
pacientes discursos que nos agrupa y a
la vez nos separan palabras cargadas de
contenido y que no significan nada
idiosincrático multifactorial primario
haciendo este análisis entonces
claramente observamos que el paradigma
donde estamos trabajando no nos prepara
y muchas veces no tenemos tiempo no
tenemos deseos de observar el resto de
las dimensiones del ser de poder ser
capaces de tratarlas la emoción lo
espiritual lo ancestral lo cultural lo
social
ubicará la vesícula al lado del apéndice
de cama 4 no hace otra cosa que
mostrarnos un sistema sanitario con una
medicina despersonalizada deshumanizada
una medicina sin sujeto
si esto fuera poco la empresa médica el
comercio el negocio está inserto en
nuestra práctica cotidiana
hemos creado la industrialización de las
necesidades y un sistema económico en
torno a la salud me voy a auto corregir
un sistema económico en torno a la
enfermedad
el bien ganancial es la enfermedad tanto
que inventamos las enfermedades no
enfermedades situaciones vitales teñidas
o disfrazadas de enfermedad no se me
puede caer un poco el pelo no puedo
tener dolor de garganta no puedo estar
cansado no puedo hacerme pis en la cama
en la primera infancia no puedo tener
algún kilo de más algún kilo de menos o
celulitis que todo esto tiene que estar
denominado enfermedad
así somos conducidos para saber si
estamos enfermos porque nos sentimos
enfermos o porque no queremos estar
enfermos a consumir medicinas
consumimos consultas consumimos
información médica tan fácilmente el
acceso de todos nosotros y con tanto
riesgo de ser mal utilizada información
conocimiento y sabiduría no son lo mismo
consumimos tecnología como médico quiero
el último aparato y como paciente quiero
que me estudien y me traten con lo
último de lo último de lo último que
trajo la tecnología a pesar de que hay
cosas que hacemos hace tanto tiempo y no
necesitan que cambiemos
consumimos medicamentos medicamentos que
a veces es más fácil tomar una pastilla
que decidirnos hacer una adecuada dieta
o ejercicio y consumimos lo que nos pone
el mercado a la mano fíjense
medicamentos en forma de golosinas
yogures y leches que nos protegen por
los próximos tres años y jabones que nos
dan una capa de superman contra todos
los gérmenes
como médicos tenemos que abrir los ojos
esto no es ni difícil ni lejano ni nuevo
esto está sucediendo hay especialidades
que tienen en cuenta hoy factores
emocionales la psiconeuroinmunología
factores espirituales los cuidados
paliativos existen eventos y congresos
jornadas académicas que reúnen a médicos
y terapeutas de otras vertientes existen
movimientos humanizadores dentro del
sistema de salud como las terapias
intensivas en algunos países e incluso
congresos que tienen en cuenta
exclusivamente las expectativas y las
vivencias del propio paciente claro el
impacto hay que darlo en las bases si no
educamos a nuestros médicos en formación
con factores humanísticos desde el
inicio de las carreras esto no se
aprende así vamos a poder más allá y sin
olvidar la ciencia y la tecnología de
sumar aspectos humanísticos a nuestra
práctica cotidiana como sociedad como
potenciales pacientes
tenemos que exigir ser tratados en todas
las dimensiones de nuestro ser así
podremos comprometernos en esta cruzada
de re humanizar la práctica asistencial
e ir de regreso y a la vez hacia un
sistema de la salud el bienestar la
felicidad
y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]